Okay, now let's talk about server and client setup, and in this first section, we will
discuss working with Perforce Client.
To get started, you will need to head over to the Perforce website and locate the Helix
P4V visual client and the Helix Core P4D server.
Your initial setup will only need a single server, and while your team members or users
will install the client, your IT department should pretty much handle the rest of the
hardware and server setup and configuration.
Helix Core does offer a free trial for up to 5 users and up to 20 workspaces.
So if you need to make your own Perforce server to try it out first, go ahead and
give that a shot.
Large, scalable hardware is not a requirement before you create your Perforce server.
Now if you do select the full version, here are some of the Perforce Helix selling points.
Full version Perforce Helix manages tens of thousands of developers and creatives, tens
of millions of daily transactions, hundreds of terabytes of data, and tens of thousands
of concurrent commits.
Once you're ready to go, download the installer and install the Perforce client and server.
Note here the server port.
It is highly recommended that you maintain your server port ID as the default, 1666.
Additionally, the command line is going to need to be installed on the server in
order to utilize Unreal Game Sync in place of the standard Perforce front-end user interface.
We'll discuss more about using Unreal Game Sync a little bit later in this course.
For now, I want to move on to discuss a little bit about hardware considerations
you should make when choosing where you store your user workspace or using your server.
So for server-side hardware, it's recommended that you consider using a Linux system
instead of Windows.
A Linux system is going to give you a significantly faster performance over a Windows-based system,
but it's not a requirement.
Most of what we'll talk about is going to be Windows-based.
Additionally, I would also make sure that on both server and client system hardware
configurations that storage systems be deeply considered.
The differences between mechanical hard drives and solid-state NVMe drives are significant.
Mechanical hard drives cannot read and write data concurrently, while solid-state NVMe drives
can read and write data concurrently.
For this reason, it is recommended that your server storage drive and client user workspace
drive are SSD NVMe hardware.
Okay, once Perforce Helix has been installed and the server depot is actively running,
the next step is to open up the connection and create the client-side user workspace.
The workspace is where your project files will live and where you will work on assets locally.
This is where everything is going to be pushed and pulled to the Perforce server depot.
I recommend naming the workspace something short, not the default Perforce-generated workspace name.
You should be aware of the OS limitations for characters and naming conventions that
you might run up against.
For example, Windows has a 255 character limit, so simplicity in naming is key.
Ultimately, your naming conventions and workspace should make sense for whatever project you're
working on, and it is expected that you're going to have multiple projects that you
and your team will be working on.
Most studios will have multiple project streams on their server and multiple user workspaces
for each of those streams.
So once you're done, you want to select the depot, select the stream that you're
actually going to work from, and then you should be good to go.
However, as you work, you may need to set up and use type maps.
Type maps are server-side information, and while the average user may not ever have to
set this up, the type map is going to be used for any number of automated functions
such as version trimming if your storage space is limited, or simply enumerating tasks
as another example.
To access the type map in Windows, just head over to the Windows PowerShell, type
in the p4-type-map command, and that should open a text doc that you'll be able to
customize, make edits, and save, implementing your automation without much fuss.
A good command-line type map example has been provided online in the Epic Games documentation.
There you will find a comprehensive type map, similar to what is pictured here in
this slide.
Alright, moving on to the Helix Client frontend.
This is your user interface, and I've broken this up into four distinct sections.
First, there is the toolbar.
It's number one.
This is where all your menu buttons are going to live.
Refresh, get latest, submit, checkout, delete, differentiate, redraft, and clone.
They're all there.
And if you're ever unsure of what each toolbar button does once you launch Perforce, just
hover over the button and Perforce will give you a short description of the button's
function.
The next window that I want to look at is number two, file versions.
This is where your depot and workspace version views are available, and you can switch between
them by clicking on the tabs for either section.
Inside those sections, you'll be able to determine what files exist where, and be able to quickly
check what is in your workspace and what is in your depot to compare versioning.
Typically, you're going to start out in the workspace when launching Perforce.
But in this particular image, I'm showing you the depot side.
Next up is number three, the work area.
The work area is where your files live.
You can see pending change lists, there's a tab for the workspace setup, which will
allow you to switch between multiple active workspaces.
Notice here that I have two showing.
One is for the unified content example version 5.2, and another one is for the version 5.3
of the same content.
Here, you can also switch over to view the history of anything that you have submitted
for work.
Below that is number four, the command line.
This is an activity log, but it also allows for anything chronicled in the command line
history to be copied and pasted for rapid scripting if needed.
Moving on to the meat of Perforce, adding project files to Perforce that you can actually
work on, we're going to talk about adding an Unreal Engine project file to Perforce.
Unreal Engine project files and folders will need to be added to the Perforce workspace
once you've created that workspace on the client-side local hard drive.
This will allow the files within that workspace to be accessible by Perforce.
Once the workspace has been created on the client's local drive, all you need to do
to add your project files is just copy the entire engine project folder from your
Unreal Engine projects folder to the workspace collaboration subfolder, as you can see here.
Just a quick note here, the hierarchy of the depot will be handled by your internal IT staff,
but a typical configuration and what we use at Epic Games starts with a specific Perforce stream.
Then under the Perforce stream, a collaboration folder is created, followed by a subfolder
or set of subfolders that allows users to organize and maintain different sections
of different projects.
For example, right now, the ILT Education Department has the Unified Content Example
folder where the ILT-UCE project lives, and that lives in both the workspace and
the depot.
If I want to add the ILT demo folder from my workspace to the project depot, I simply
need to drag it over to the same workspace location.
Now you might be wondering, what is that going to look like in Perforce once those
project folders and files have been added to the client local workspace?
Well, for Perforce to have access to the folder and files, all I need to do is refresh
that workspace inside the Perforce workspace window, and that's going to show the folders
and files that have been moved to that workspace.
Typically the refresh happens automatically, so you don't have to actively refresh unless
you don't see anything.
However, that doesn't mean that those folders and files have been pushed to the Perforce
depot just yet.
In order to get those folders and files up onto the depot so that they can be shared
and accessed by multiple users, I need to select only a few specific folders and files
from inside the Perforce workspace file version window.
Those specific folders are the Unreal Engine config folder, the content folder, and the
Unreal Engine uProject file for my project.
Once you have those folders and files selected, right-click on one of them and that will
bring up a pop-up menu.
This menu will have the option to mark your files for add.
When you mark the files for add, another menu is going to pop up, allowing you to
create a pending changelist.
When you first start out, that changelist that you're going to create is going to
be a new one, and you can select that from the drop-down menu.
You'll note here in the changelist description, I've added hashtag preflight to the start
of my description list.
That is because there may be a project or stream lockdown in effect for different
projects within Epic Games, and there may be changes to things going on behind the
scenes that prevent a standard upload.
You won't necessarily need to use this in your preflight or pending changelist.
When you first start out, that changelist that you're going to create is going to be
a new one, and you can select that from the drop-down menu as an option.
You'll note here in the changelist description that I've added a hashtag preflight to the
start of my description text.
That is because there may be a project or stream lockdown in effect for different projects
within Epic Games, and there may be changes to things going on behind the scenes that
may prevent a standard upload.
It's not always necessary to add this to your description.
Adding the specific hashtag preflight tag should allow me to bypass any lockdown blockades
so that my submission continues to go through without disturbing other streams.
After that tag, I give a normal description of what I'm actually submitting, what I'm
doing to make my change, and also notating that I am the user making this change.
Basically, I'm putting my name on it.
Once I'm ready, then I just go ahead and click OK to create my pending changelist.
From there, I might notice that hey, I forgot to add my source folder to that changelist.
Source files like Maya, ZBrush, or any FBX file that I want to keep outside of the
Unreal Engine project so that I might revise that again later can be added to the same
pending changelist, or if I've already submitted that changelist, I can just create
a new one for that submission.
Process works exactly the same way.
I just select and right-click those files or folder that I want to mark for add, and
then if I still have an existing changelist that I haven't submitted yet, I can choose
that changelist by selecting it from the pull-down menu that appears on the same
pop-up menu.
I don't have to change anything in the description because everything that I'm adding
is already there, and then just go ahead and hit OK.
What that's going to do is create a pending changelist file inside the work area window
in Perforce.
That is indicated by a red changelist triangle showing the active changelist waiting to be
submitted and uploaded to the depot.
To make that submission, just right-click on that red pending changelist and choose
Submit.
One thing to note, sometimes if you select only the folder and mark for add, the files
within that folder may not be marked.
If that happens, you will need to go in and select each file individually and then
mark for add your entire selection.
Once you choose to submit, you'll get another pop-up menu that will allow you to review
all the files that are being submitted through the pending changelist.
If everything looks good, just hit the Submit button, and then the Submit changelist progress
bar will appear.
From there, you want to verify that the files you've uploaded are now in the depot.
So you're going to switch from your workspace view to the depot view inside the
Perforce version window.
You'll also want to verify that the log shows the submission of all the files that you had
marked for add.
You'll note here in the image for the log that shows the 347 files that were first
added and then also lists the two additional files that were added later.
When I submitted for the new changelist, 349 total files were added to the depot,
verifying that all my files were added to the depot successfully.
I can verify this visually by seeing that the project folder and files are now located
under the ILT demo folder inside the ILT EDU depot folder.
All those project files are now marked with a green indicator dot showing that they
are active and ready to be checked out by other users that might need to work on them.
Alright, that's it for this section.
In our next section, we will continue discussing server-client setup and working with ShotGrid.